stop there yeah
look like a cheesy
can ever prepare you though for that
real-life situation
to
so we are going to meet after this next
week sometime
I mean this is what we trained for this
is what we trained for I mean this is
this is why we chose to go in these
professions but it when it's actually
happening in the scale that it is
happening it becomes surreal and you
have to just focus compartmentalize you
know attend to what's going on at that
moment why I do what I do
controlled chaos staff everywhere a
number of folks in different roles
attending to the roles and a few people
in the middle kind of directing traffic
you go here you go here I need this I
need that we mobilized resources from
make sure we had several rooms set up
one of the things that happened in
advance of our receipt of patients with
EMS contacted us and asked our
capabilities there are two trauma
centers in the area and they wanted you
know when we had some sense of how many
victims were arriving how many can we
handle how many we did we want to direct
to the other facility
so
check
I'm sorry I would also say that probably
would distract from our ability to focus
on the issue at hand I think that you
know in the initial received patient
that's not a good time for us to be
asking questions about the situation
so the first awareness we had that there
was an incident occurring the first was
almost all preparation it took a while
to stabilize the scene to get the
patients transported receive that first
patient once we started receiving
patients it was a sort of a dividing
conquer scenario that we had physicians
in each trauma room we had staff these
probably women and we focused on our
particular patient
and making sure that they had the
resources they need and we're stabilized
trauma physicians sort of were aware of
every patient making decisions about who
need to devote where next to me to go
video are we need to go to the ICU how
to transition them through the emergency
so EMS EMS had established a local
on-site command system and they were in
contact with the emergency department
our charge nurse in the positions in the
emerge department as we had updates on
number victims number that were to be
transported they were in constant
communication with the emergency
department as I mentioned before how
many patients are you prepared to take
identifying the capabilities that the
hospitals in the area and who can
receive what we were able to do that EMS
response system divert non trauma
ambulances from our facility to other
non trauma facilities for the time care
that we receive new trauma victims so
that we can focus our resources entirely
on the trauma situation it really was
the best
all the gunshot wound victims pay my
ambulance desperate
- two deceased
and as much as Virginia Beach is a city
this is our friends or neighbors we all
have beginning and an end to our
responsibility but this is something
that will continue to affect the family
personal video sort of
and when you know one of the things in
the beginning phases of this situations
it's a very controlled environment
families weren't free to come and go to
the hospital
place for families to go to get
information the police were the ones
controlling that sharing of information
so earlier on that wasn't that
opportunity
20 years 45 + 35 +
thirty years